how do we thrive in a world where every
which way we turn our fear is being
activated by politicians by the media
and by the desperate events that are
happening around us what is really
fascinating when we look at the brain
research around fear is that our brains
proxy anything that feels unfamiliar
incoherent or inaccessible as being
unsafe so let me give you an example
there is fascinating research that shows
that when people have lower levels of
self-esteem and they are in a job in
which they are recognized and promoted
that promotion can feel incoherent to
the person with low self-esteem they
have low self-esteem and they might be
used to and expecting to be treated
badly so what is fascinating is the
results showing that when people are
promoted when they have lower levels of
self esteem they are more likely to
leave their jobs fear is an incredibly
incredibly powerful force in our lives
and our brains are fairly immature in
assessing anything that feels slightly
incoherent or unfamiliar as unsafe what
this might mean is that if you are used
to hearing a story time and time again
from a parent or from a partner about
how you are not good enough
you are more likely to be drawn to that
relationship because it feels familiar
the messaging that you are getting time
and time again
is connected with what you expect to get
when we have politicians who are
effectively demagogues who are inspiring
fear in us that fear leads to very
particular and relatively predictable
responses when we are fearful there is
this idea in psychological research of
mortality salience that when our
mortality is threatened when someone
says oh this group of people is out to
get you and we feel that we are actively
being threatened we are more likely to
stereotype we are more likely as
individuals to become bigoted we are
more likely to respond to messages that
we hear time and time again even if they
are against our values as somehow making
sense to us how do we protect ourselves
against this Daniel Kahneman describes
system 1 thinking and system 2 thinking
system 1 thinking is the intuitive
response the emotional visceral
us-and-them
that can sometimes arise out of fear
system 2 is the deliberate thoughtful
examination of what is this person
saying is it aligned with how I really
want to be is it connected with how I
really wanted to raise my children is
this a world that I want to support when
we are able to step back from our fear
not to pretend that it doesn't exist but
to see our fear for what it is
fear not a direction but data and an
emotion when we are able to step back
from the fear and able to assess
fear and assess the messaging from the
place of our values in a more deliberate
thoughtful way we are able to come to a
place where we are ultimately protected
from the demagoguery message from the
message of fear and are able to move
ourselves forward in a way that is
aligned with how we truly want to be and
with the world that we truly want to
live in when Donald Trump first started
with all of this messaging we used to
hear things that the politicians would
say and we would be like oh my goodness
how can the person possibly say that
thing but what happens over time is the
more familiar something sounds so the
more we've heard it time and time again
even if the story is inaccurate even if
the story doesn't serve us the more we
are likely to become inured to it and
immune to it so what I actually think
from a media perspective is when I speak
to people in the media about this they
will often say well we simply go where
the story takes us so we'll give as much
coverage to whatever the story's at even
if the story is one that incites hatred
or violence but I actually think that
there is a very very powerful ethical
choice that the media makes in that
because when they expose and expose and
expose and expose a story that is about
hatred and a story that is about
violence as human beings the more
familiar we become with that story
the more in nerd we become to it and I
think we can see exactly this in the
current elections that things that were
said six months ago where everyone was
horrified that a politician could
possibly even prevail on people to
listen to what was being said are now
being met with oh you know there we go
again we somehow has become
nerd to the messaging because of the
familiarity with which we are hearing it
and I think it's really important for us
as a society and for us as voters to
recognize that a familiar story is not
necessarily a truthful story a familiar
story might sound comfortable and our
brains might proxy that story for
meaning safe and therefore right and
therefore comfortable but that story
doesn't necessarily reflect us or what
we value and it's really important to be
able to step out from the safety of what
might at this point feel familiar and
really recognize the words for what they
are there are words that are inciting
hatred and division and stereotyping in
us as a society and for many of us
that's not the society in which we want
to live and I think there's a moral
impetus on us to be able to step back
from the story and step forward with our
values